If the Blue Fairy appears, it symbolizes nature. So, what I'm trying to say, is that the medical will give the kids (a space of time, or help)
If you feel that nature is the back of the mother for example
But even living for other people, sometimes
Because we are used to accepting the actions of children that we do not usually accept from others
Enough, nature pardons.
Here she appears in her angelic appearance, she says
what is happening? And Pinocchio (cartoon character)
Also, because he is naïve and abnormal
He is not evil either. It is not both together or it may be. It all depends on how you think things are.
And
Or has no idea of ​​his intelligence, intelligence, or intelligence level
Rather than acknowledging his action
He is lying
This is interesting because this suggests
He knows to a certain degree that he will sign himself in the future.
Because as you know, he could have told the truth
This evil fox
"He kidnapped me and sold me to one of the slaves"
And this is ... the truth, is more true than the story he said
He tells a story about a monster
Fantastic monster
He could have said three-quarters of the truth, but he did not.
But the reality of the story is complete and this is the part that people remember from the story
I have been editing this section for years when I talk about this film
I forgot why this is so important.
Khashmah grow up, right?
Grow up until you reach an absurd height
And why get this ??
I think Mark Twain
Identified by Samuel Clemens, I think it is he who said:
"One of the advantages of telling the truth is that you do not have to remember what you said"
And - God, this is exciting and worthy of listening to it
Well, there are a lot of lichens that I learned and I'm in the clinic
One of them is that, where in many cases you are sometimes awkward with people, if you are a doctor at the clinic
Because some of the licia occurs. Often occurring does not occur normally.
And you do not know how to behave in these situations.
Then, what I learned is to say what is happening now
No matter what it is, I'm just trying to explain it
In the same way, and not more concerned about its consequences
As you know, I'm not looking for problems but
If you are in ... this may save you and save your life sometimes
Especially if you are working with a frightened person and is very paranoid
Do not lie to a frightened and violent person
Because when you lie, you make yourself an ally of the forces that are trying to destroy it immediately
This panic makes the patient more alert as if under the influence of drug (amphetamines - a kind of prohibited drugs)
In fact it can make people terrified when you give them (amphetamines)
And can be made more panic by giving them a stronger dose of the drug (amphetamine)
Well, they are more alert,
Because they feel everything about them is against them
And they watch you in a way that they believe in much more than they do
And when you mess with a lie when you talk to them, you're done for them
If one thing is mocked it is when you are in a very bad situation and you do not know what to do
You have to tell the truth always, but with very little. Do not say much because this is another lie.
Just say the least cautiously possible truth and hopefully he can get out of the situation.
Maybe you get out of the situation .. Maybe you get out of it
But when you visit the facts
be careful
The truth is a defense mechanism to get out of the predicament and dangerous situations
If someone is trying to scare you and you think he can turn into a violent person.
And they ask you are you afraid. Then tell them that you are very terrified and wish that things will end well
Or say
I will give you an example
One time I was at the airport
We were in the queue of the plane leaving for Canada and this is the international flight queue
The queue was very long, almost 50 people
There were 3 people in front of me, and about 40 rear
The person in charge decided to close the track and told us to go all the way to the other line, which had about 300 people
I suggested that he do not. Because we had been in the queue for about an hour
And he can finish our column with the remaining 20 people
And take the idea,
But he called the police immediately
This was in Florida and after 9/11
The police came heavily armed
And he told them that he was making trouble
But I did not do anything but I did not ..
I did not make ...
How can I say it?
I did not do anything except that I did not make the ignorant bureaucratic bugger take advantage of me and this is not like making problems
Well anyway, once the police arrived I told them to look
I will do what they ask me immediately
I am not a source of problems
But I want you to hear what exactly happened to me
This is a good example of what you should do in such situations
If there are those who have been able to
Do not boast, this is a very bad idea
And I am ready to do whatever they ask of me, for as you know
They did not know who I was. I also do not know what they were told about me
In any case
The problem with lying is that it is like multiple visions
And children know this since childhood.
Because when you say lies, you have consequences that you might get away with
Maybe it has 3 or 4 consequences you did not realize and did not expect
It is relatively large in complexity
And then you have to link his lie to another smaller
And you have to track them and they also grow 3 other complications and quickly
This little lie grows into a big ball of lies, and it becomes perfectly clear to all
And then .. you see that when politicians lie. Such as a politician who was sending sexual messages
Student: Anthony Weiner (Political Name)
Anthony Weiner True! A perfect name for that person. That's funny...
I do not have to say this comment because it is obvious and clear, yet it is funny.
But as you know exactly what happened to him
Not the event itself
But people are stupid and they make mistakes
In fact, they forgive forgery, if you say
"Well I'm a fool how I did it but I did it, because I repeat it in the future"
But what happens with politicians
I do not talk about politicians in particular, but when they do, it immediately appears
They lie 3 other lies to cover the matter
This happened with President Nixon, for example
And then it turned into a scandal
And maybe they got out of the mess right from the start if they told the truth
They admitted, "Yes, I'm an idiot and I will not repeat it again"
Well, that's not what happened with Pinocchio
He repeated his lies so much that the Blue Fairy came and was gracious with him, because he was attractive and a puppet
She forgave him this time only and said to him: Do not repeat this again
And it will not be there to help him in the future.